welcome everybody to the into the
impossible podcast a production of the
arthur c
clarke center for human imagination at
uc san diego
and uh we are named after one of sir
arthur c clarke's famous three laws the
first one being
for any expert there's an equal and
opposite
expert the second one being
the uh the any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic and the third one being the only
way to find out what is possible is to
venture beyond
a bit into the impossible so sabine
that's where we get it
i think you exemplify many of those
different laws of you know you're an
expert
oftentimes you're oppositional to other
experts and putting them in their
rightful places
you work on advanced technology in the
form of higher
mathematics and physics and you've done
the impossible because you've
you've actually communicated science to
a whole generation of people in a very
technical
level but not dumbing down anything you
do and
i have so much respect for your book
which is coming out in paperback so
first i want to welcome you uh dr sabine
hassenfelder from
joining us all the way from germany
right now where it's late in the evening
thank you so much for joining us on the
podcast sabine
uh thank you in return and it's good to
see you brian
yeah it's good to see you too you know i
was looking back because i was going to
email you we've been communicating via
twitter direct messages which is you
know probably the least effective form
of communication but
it works it works okay um and then i
look back i gotta have her email
somewhere and
i looked up and like there was an email
invitation that you had sent me
uh for a conference in 2009 uh which
i think was at nordita that took place
maybe it was 2010
and that was actually when uh when we
found out about it when we went there i
took my wife
and we found out uh you know kind of
along the way that we were pregnant with
our
first child than nine years ago and i
suspect that you were
pregnant also with your first and second
child right
yeah that's right so that was a
legendary conference
that was great i loved that conference
except for the accommodations it was the
hottest time ever
oh yeah oh my god i remember this it was
so terrible
yeah i was so sorry about it yeah but it
was nice because it actually got me
you know club my first exposure to the
uh to the enthralling world of the nobel
prizes
and and so forth and even took a detour
over there
um i want to point out for my i tweeted
about this today that you're my
fifth guest and if you include me i've
been a guest on my own podcast i suppose
uh six guests out of you know 50
episodes have twins
it's pretty remarkable so i'm very proud
of that and of course
we realized that in mathematics or sorry
in relativity theory
einstein was guided by these gudenkin
experiments these so-called thought
experiments
and uh he was a theorist but he dabbled
an experiment
and much of what i think interests me
about your work
is to see how a real you know a theorist
looks at things
but with an eye towards what can we
prove and what can we say about things
so first of all i want to talk about uh
your wonderful book lost in math which
came out
two years ago in hardcover and is coming
out next week in
uh paperback can you talk a little bit
about that book what led you to
to write it because it's not an ordinary
popular science book with whiz-bang
wormholes and
it's almost not only is it almost the
opposite of that but it's it's a
it's a memoir and it's a it's a i call
it the heroine's journey
you know where you kind of make this
travel log across the world can you talk
about what motivated you to write it
and what it was like writing that book
so um the book is about me trying to
make sense of what is going on in the
foundations of physics
um where we have all these people
looking for
uh you know theory of everything uh
grant unified theories
uh trying to reinvent the foundations of
quantum mechanics
and at some point i just couldn't
understand anymore
why they are doing what they are doing
and so that's when i set out on this
journey which i
um write about in the book so i talk to
people in the field
and ask them like uh what's going on
what do you think you're doing
please explain it to me and i try to
communicate
this to the reader which was so
it was quite some challenge because
um so with the exception i think of
um stephen weinberg
everyone who i talked to knew that i'm a
physicist so
even though i told them like please
don't be too technical because i won't
be able to put this in a book they would
you know they would start immediately
talking about the details and so then i
had to
try to explain this in the book
so so it was quite difficult to make
this work
um but in the end i think it worked out
fine
so you have you have these interviews
with uh me and between explaining uh
what's going on
and um i made a lot of effort to put it
in the right order so there would be no
gaps
um yeah so um you know it's basically a
portrait
of what's going on in the foundations of
physics
and towards the end of the book i try to
put this into
the broader context of the general
problems that we have
um with um
you know in in other scientific
disciplines
um or all the all the trouble that can
happen
from the pressure that a lot of people
are under
you know financial pressure time
pressure the pressure to publish
um the pressure to get something done
within
in um the constraints of a little
grant that you have and it's it's not
working very well i think
um and so in the foundations of physical
i think it's it's particularly
pronounced because we have this
detachment
from experimental checks and
many of the questions that we're trying
to
answer are just so so hard
you basically can't get anywhere within
two or three years
and you know when i read read the book
it speaks to me
first of all i learned a lot from it not
only what
uh what your perspective is is a unique
one in that
you know the attraction to beauty and to
symmetry and all sorts of things are
leading
scientists to really forget what is
unique about science and that it isn't
art and uh i kept thinking as i'm
reading it you know have you ever seen
these pictures where they take like brad
pitt
uh you know who's the handsomest man in
in the world according to
the reputable science journal called
people magazine here in america
are okay and they take his face and they
split it in half
and then they mirror reflect one half
onto the other so it's perfectly
symmetrical
at least you know parody symmetrical and
he looks grotesque and you know this is
the
most attractive man in the world so it
started making me think that
is it really true that that you know
great beauty
is truly symmetric or is it just a
cop-out or is it just a
shortcut a mental hack to use symmetry
to avoid doing things in other words is
physics actually more
symmetric than than even art is
well symmetry is not the only kind of
beauty of course
um so i think the reason uh even the the
supposedly most beautiful man looks uh
terrible
if you do that kind of thing is that we
realize immediately it's unnatural
um so it just freaks us out right so
this is not a
a real human being i think that's where
it comes from psychologically
uh but i mean it is well established
that
um our sense for symmetry
very very likely has an evolutionary um
origin you know we we we like
things that are symmetrical because in
many
instances symmetry is a sign of health
so it makes sense that we like it
but it doesn't make any sense that we
expect
nature on the most fundamental level
to appeal to this very sense of beauty
that we take from
apples basically right
and so this is what leaves me perplexed
that
um scientists don't question this
like why why am i using this criterion
why do i rely so much
on this sense of duty if there is no
reason
to think that it actually tells me
something
about what i'm trying to achieve uh in
this case
um trying to understand i don't know the
quantum nature of space and time
or something like that um so yeah so in
in the foundations of physics uh we have
this this very peculiar problem that
um arguments from beauty have become
very commonplace
and um very few people question it
it's just because everyone is doing it
uh it seems to
have become okay
yeah and i wonder you know if i'm trying
to show a picture of me with
someone named max tegmark at uh mit when
we
without the hands no heads so they're
you know he's extremely attractive even
when you cut off his head apparently
so i'll switch back to your cover um so
we talk about
um physicists and especially
theoreticians i
have yet to really see an
experimentalist
focus on beauty as a criterion although
i do want to get into that uh
for a bit because and and you and i met
again about a year and a half ago
in los angeles talking about your book
in front of other
you know basically all theoretical
physicists except for me or
mathematicians
including eric weinstein stefan
alexander and
and priya naratagen and and others and
the question was you know what what is
about what is it about this
the topics and the kind of issues raised
in at least what i call the polemical
your book is really divided in at least
two parts one is a polemic about
this very issue and the perniciousness
that it may
prove to be for physics and progress in
the 21st century
but it's also this travelogue and this
you know heroine's journey
around the planet literally and there's
so many delightful scenes in there but
um but i tried to make the point in that
gathering of you know brainiacs
that you know beauty is essential or you
know to an experiment like there
there are experiments which aren't
beautiful but but experiment you know
like the transistor if you've ever seen
the first transition you know it's a
a piece of chewing gum over here a
crystal there and
a coat hanger there and it's magically
work so i mean
it's beautiful judged by its results but
for example when i we just put out a
paper
on the polar bear team which i'm a part
of which is a cosmic microwave
background polarization experiment who
has an ultimate goal
to measure and constrain uh the
existence or lack thereof of primordial
perturbations in the metric of
space-time potentially caused by
gravitational waves
potentially the byproduct of inflation
which is potentially a harbinger
of the multiverse so you have all these
different chains and we'll get into each
one of those and i know your feelings
are very well known on those but i want
to recapitulate them to the audience so
now i have this experiment
and along the way we can't we spent six
months with a graduate student working
on this to be precise
and her advisors you know they spent six
to nine months looking for
departures from symmetry in other words
we're doing null tests we're doing
we're trying to torture the data in as
many ways as possible
that should yield a zero signal and yet
every time we do that we find there are
some departures for that and
that's a form of symmetry would would
you agree
sure there are many forms of symmetry so
let me
maybe be a little bit more precise what
what the problem is with these arguments
from beauty it's not that
per se that physicists like to talk
about beauty because
as you say you know experimentalists
talk about beauty
and i don't think that's necessarily a
problem
it becomes a problem if a large
community has a very
narrow sense of beauty and
that becomes an entrenched methodology
that they are not willing to give up on
even though it's clearly not working
so um i i have no problem
uh with people who value beauty
uh in in mathematics or in their work in
general
um it becomes a problem if it's it's a
if it's a dogmatic
um a trend in the community
and maybe i should add there that um i
guess a lot of theoretical physicists
uh uh would be um insulted
uh that i talk about um beauty and
accuse them of you
using uh notions of beauty um because
they uh by and large don't understand
what they are doing
so um i i was in a debate just on on the
weekend with
um jim baggett and he says he prefers to
call it
metaphysical commitment and uh
that's entirely right that's what it is
it's a metaphysical commitment they have
certain ideas of how their theories are
supposed to look like that are not
themselves
um scientific but they use them
nevertheless
why don't i call it metaphysical
commitment
because you can't put that on a cover of
basically
so this is why i talk about beauty i
also think that
historically it's actually where it came
from you know it was the sense of beauty
that people
like to talk about but now they're using
notions of beauty like this uh
idea of technical naturalness that you
have now high energy physics
that are just mathematical criteria and
they don't
uh understand that these are actually
metaphysical commitments
and you know you talk a little bit about
the book in in the book about this most
famous
or um you know kind of exponent of
beauty which is none other than the
nobel prize winner
i can't decide if you use the word nobel
prize more in your book or i use
mine in my book in fact at one point you
say you make
you make an offhand comment about brian
greene and you put in parentheses he has
not yet won a nominee
uh so i thought that was pretty funny
but you you um mention a character who's
familiar to all physicists and is
sort of the paragon for the maybe the
anti-sabine school of thought which is
you know
uh physicist paul dirac who basically
said things tend to amount to
you know that you're you know it's more
important that your equations are
beautiful
than that they're correct and i can't
think of anything more anathema to an
experimentalist than such a
such a statement but it brings up this
notion of what is correct
mean and uh what i wanted to get your
you know and you've talked about this
and and i should mention for the
listeners
sabine runs a phenomenal project um
which is to explain some of the most
complicated
concepts in all of physics and astronomy
on her youtube channel so we'll have a
link to your youtube channel
and also on your on your blog which is
renowned around the world the back
reaction blog
uh and that uh that can also um uh be
located in the show notes that i'll
include
but um so dirac i mean direct casts a
very long shadow
as i said before we started recording i
had on eric weinstein a couple weeks ago
and he
really you know does seem to uh hold
this high regard for
for the equations and almost considering
the incrementalism
that uh that has taken over physics
since the times of the diracs and the
fineman's
as you know kind of the tailor who puts
on the last button but is building on
the superstructure
you know that hasn't changed in 50 to 70
years depending on what you're what
you're calculating what you're what
you're discussing
but i wonder do you think that that that
physicist
as you know sort of looking at us as a
sociological
study group do you think that we're
driven by these kind of
cults of personality that we we either
follow whitten or we follow kamran vapha
or we follow
established do you feel like there's too
much because i don't think
it's the case in experiment again an
experiment you might have
a school of thinking but but there's so
many
thousands of people that are needed for
billion dollar plus experiments that
there's really no one person who can
dictate the taste of a field
you know for decades to come at least
until after he or she wins a nobel prize
and sometimes it happens but usually
they're in their 80s
so so what what do you make about that
is there a bifurcation in the culture of
physics between
theorists who might have this guru
kind of mentality um versus experiment
so maybe you just speak to is that
something that you've observed in your
in your many travels
well i didn't talk to uh
experimentalists so really i can't tell
i can only tell you what's with the
theorists right
and even in that case i i can't
you know promise that i'm giving you a
representative sample it's just a sample
of people that i happen to have spoken
to
um so i'm i mean
look these are all really smart people
um right
so to some level i don't think it can
get
too bad i mean they they do a
significant amount of self reflection
and i don't think that anyone would
just dumply repeat what iraq
has been saying and take this to be like
the word of the master and that's what
i'm going to do
that that's not how it works right um
but
certainly i mean what what you see a lot
i think
in in among um theoreticians
is that they by and large still believe
in this idea of the lone genius
you know i'm going to sit here and think
really really hard
about how nature works and it will come
to me and
everyone will understand that
you know i figured it all out and i will
be famous and get a nobel prize
basically
so that's where many of these people
seem to be coming from
and um you know i i
blame a lot of uh popular science books
for that which have uh propagated this
this myth
of uh you know there's this genius uh
may that be einshine or drock
or feynman or who have you who
basically figured out how nature works
um just because they were super smart
leaving aside that they were embedded in
this large community of people
who they could exchange their ideas with
and um so you have now this community of
theoreticians who believe that that's
how their research is supposed to work
completely ignore that they too are part
of this community
and um this creates a
a lot of problems i think and
as as you point out you know in in
experiment i think people are
more used to being dependent on other
people
um you have these huge communities and
everyone's doing their part
and really the magic comes from everyone
working together on something
so so you just have fewer people who are
you know insistent on
on going it alone um though one
shouldn't you know over exaggerate this
i mean they're
also in of course in in theory you also
have people working together
uh right uh everyone's working together
with someone i just mean to say you
don't get these huge
uh collaborations um right and when you
look at
science so one thing that came up you
know as many times i've had on stephen
wolfram
and eric weinstein stephan alexander jen
11.
and frequently i've discussed with them
and and sylvester
jim gates as well talking about this
this notion that at least in my opinion
physicists have a certain amount of math
envy naturally and i think in theory
it's obvious it comes up a lot more but
um but in that at least mathematics you
know the limits of what cannot be proven
or at least you know that
certain things cannot be proven if
mathematics is complete by virtue of
girdles in completeness theorem
but there is no equivalent for for
physics for
physical laws physical quantities
parameters
what have you and i feel like physicists
are
used as a proxy the karl popper's
demarcation
hypothesis which really was never
intended to
be the arbiter of what is good science
what is correct you know he was really
really making a distinction between
astrology
and astronomy i mean he for one view the
steady state model is much more
compelling
based on parsimony and occam's razor
type arguments
but nevertheless i think physicists have
this you know desire
to want to you say that popper is the
be-all end-all arbiter
and you talk a lot in the book about how
you know running through the themes of
your own personal travels are the
travels of the travails of the field
where you're you know just die photon
excess and everyone gets excited there's
500 papers that come out about it
and uh and then it just goes away and
i'm wondering if this
is this a byproduct of the stagnation of
progress in your opinion um that
you know there's so few and far between
discoveries and discoveries take so much
time and money to make
in the experimental field that now we
just have popularizers of science that
can
that can hype it up maybe beyond the
level that it's warranted
um so you've brought up a lot of points
there sorry so
maybe let me start with a brief remark
about the math
envy uh so i i don't fully understand
your remark about google because uh
needless to say a theorem is a theorem
so it applies of course
uh to the mathematics that we use in
physics
right so but what the difference is that
uh
in physics we're never quite sure that
the mesomatics that we are using is
actually ultimately the right one
so you can always ask like maybe that's
a better piece of math that would not
uh you know be affected by this no-go
theorem
and and there are certainly a lot of
no-go theorems for
one thing or the other thing um and i do
think that these
theorems are um enormously useful you
know
they tell you what you can and cannot do
within the context of a given
um theory um so i think math
is awesome uh basically um
sound bite theoretical physicist claims
math is awesome
yeah maybe i should add that so i
originally studied math
um okay so mathematical
i fell off faith and because i guess i
just mean that i hear a lot you know
that oh it's this is not falsifiable
therefore
i mean nobody's disputing the
unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics and physics to use
wigner's term right but um how is it
possible that
um an experimental physicist you know
for example you have this
you have this discussion with garrett
lisey who's a
ucsd alum and uh you know he's basically
saying like well
you can't prove that you can't prove
this about and and so it's untestable
and
and you kind of badger him a little bit
in the friendly way well i bet the
masses of your particles are just you
know well beyond the horizon of
detectability
but um what if there was i mean people
say just to cut it
hi sabine sorry there you are yeah
sorry i got uh i got kicked off for some
reason but uh should be better
so uh i was event i was asking you've
no doubtedly heard that people will say
well string theory is not really
so the audio is not it's good yeah hold
on the audio is not good
let me try one more thing hold on
i'll edit this out um
okay is that better
is that any better so i hear you at
least
so that's better than not hearing you
i guess yeah let me see uh one last
thing i have a
hard wire connection and a wi-fi
connection maybe they're battling each
other and that's the problem
um okay this should be better is this
better
yeah well i'll say something can you
hear me now with my
yes i hear you yes good okay so this
this should work better
so i was asking i i i i let me tell you
where i lost you you said something
about
unreasonable no one doubts the
unreasonable effectiveness
and then oh yeah so the famous uh it is
a wigner's
statement that the you know what's
unusual is how unreasonable
mathematics is in physics and nobody's
doubting that math is
used for various purposes in physics but
the problem is how do you determine
if a theory like string theory or the
multiverse etc paradigms
if they you know if as it's often stated
not directly by you
i don't think but that it can't be
falsified so let's not
let's not i mean it's often used as a
way to dismiss
something by a critics of string theory
oh it can't be tested it can't be
falsified so therefore it's not science
as if popper is the ultimate arbiter of
what's right and wrong the way that
girdle
is the arbiter of what can be provable
or not within the context of mathematics
does that make sense
proper reliance there are many things
just
to be said about this one thing is that
popper didn't use falsification
as the one and only way to tell
signs from pseudoscience so that's just
that's just rubbish and actually i think
that this is
um part of the problem that you see
in high energy phenomenology and in
other
related areas that they tend to think
that just because
they are able to make a potentially
falsifiable prediction in science
which is nonsense of course um and
they use this to excuse
a lot of mathematics basically
and hide all their guesswork in some
kind of equation but that's in the end
that's exactly what it is it's some
guesswork
and so you were talking about this um
daiphoton
anomaly um that disappeared so i tell
this story in my book where they
had these 600 papers that were published
uh within a matter
of a month and this highlights exactly
this problem
uh they believe that this is good
science largely because
um you know that they are making some
kind of
prediction basically so maybe that's not
the best example now that i think about
it because
it wasn't even a prediction it was a
postdictionary there's a retroduction
um yeah so not even that in
in this case um but um you know if you
look at the
phenomenological models that people are
using like for super symmetry you know
you have all these uh
super symmetric um these variations of
supersymmetry that
supposedly tell you what's the mass of
this or that particle all the dark
matter
uh models and so on that's all
supposedly signs because they make some
kind of
prediction and so i think this is just
wrong
um and this of course also means that
you can't just go
and dismissed string theory because it's
supposedly
um non-falsifiable so i should add here
that this isn't even true
string theory is in principle
falsifiable
um i mean it predicts that
the world's made of strings i mean
that's that's a prediction
the problem is that it's it's
unfalsifiable in practice
you know no one no one's going to see
these things uh in the next 1000 years
or something
um so really that's that's not
the problem uh with um
with string theory of multiverses uh and
so on
really the problem is that um these
theories
are just unnecessary to begin with they
don't actually solve any problem they
don't constitute any kind of progress
and so this brings up the question again
like then why
do theorists work on this stuff
nevertheless and that's because they
think it's prettier
like so you put up this uh image about
super symmetry um yeah
you can ask well why do they believe in
that but because they think it would be
pretty
if there was some kind of symmetry
relating the fermions on the bosons
yeah and and there are symmetries that
relate you know octets and
i mean there symmetry has played a huge
role in uh
construction of what's known as a
standard model so it's not without
justification that i mean it shouldn't
be your starting point and
and i guess your point is that too many
people say well let's look for something
that's incredibly beautiful
uh but that might be just a mental
shortcut a hack
you know to get to the answer faster
perhaps
um well you you shouldn't
lose the problem that you're trying to
solve out of sight
so um you're right of course symmetries
have been very useful
uh in physics so
it it made sense after the standard
model was largely completed
to try to increase the symmetry
and see if that works and that's exactly
what people did in the 1980s
but the thing is it did not work yeah
you know they they tried these grand
unified theories one after the other and
they were ruled out well after the other
they've been looking for supersymmetry
uh also since the 1980s uh and basically
was ruled out in the 1990s
uh it's just that they didn't give up on
it uh instead they
you know fixed the theory so it was
still um
in agreement with data and then it was
supposed to be found
at the tevatron and at lap and then it
was to be found at the lhc and each time
this didn't happen
they came up with some excuse and and so
so that really is the problem that
they're not learning from their mistakes
and and that's really
you know the most important thing in
science
is that you learn from the data you get
and exactly that's not happening and
that's really the problem
so when you uh you wrote an article an
op-ed for the new york times
about a year or so ago and it generated
a tremendous amount of heat
and even some ad hominem attacks which i
you know
you don't need me to defend you but i do
take offense at
people in my field usually they're men
that are you know perhaps
there's some level of insecurity when
they see someone as successful
at communicating ideas as you uh but
there were some legitimate
uh complaints that i heard from my
colleagues that i took as legitimate and
i'm going to take the opportunity
to just level them you know level them
at you know crush you no i'm not going
to do that
but you're impervious anyway but one of
the arguments was
you know that you're making is that uh
you know we should be careful building
this future
linear collider so there's a picture of
it an artist impression behind
me and it just engulfs the lhc
and uh and and part of what you're
saying is certainly legitimate that you
know of course you can always say we
just need a little bit more energy we
need a little bit more money
we need a little bit more time but these
are all finite resources
on the other hand we in the usa learned
a very painful lesson in 1993 i was a
beginning graduate student
and i remember the moping faces in the
high energy physics department
you know part of the physics department
at brown university just
devastated by the cancellation of the
superconducting super collider
and for about a millisecond i didn't
understand it i said well
they'll just use the money for something
cool you know besides that they'll build
some other you know a giant telescope
but that never happens and and in fact
that was very naive of me to suspect
that so
where where do you you know really come
off in this
in this conversation because what you
say carries a lot of weight
uh people listen to you um and i think
your voice is extremely important
when you say like we shouldn't build
something like this you're really saying
like physics doesn't need funding or or
perhaps
um you know it shouldn't the physics
shouldn't receive this funding so my
question i guess is to you
you know given that that money is not
going to be used for physics
uh do you think that we really shouldn't
argue for making advances even if
they're incremental
uh do you think that runs a risk of
maybe damaging
you know progress in physics albeit it
might be less
you know uh quantum leaps than we would
like
um okay so so a few things one thing is
that
you said the future linear collided
sorry circuit yeah i have fcc and
yeah yeah i was like wait wait what's he
doing sorry well there is one ai
lc right there's a chinese one at least
nemo
yeah yeah right but i think the one
that's behind you it's definitely not
linear
right so um yeah now about this argument
with the super conducting super collider
this is like one of the most
common complaints that i get uh and it's
just rubbish
uh so for for everyone use intros that i
have
on my blog uh a list with the most
common nonsense arguments for building a
bigger collider
and that's like i think it's number one
or two
um and and so this argument that like um
if we don't build this larger collider
it is not necessarily
going to be used in the foundations of
physics um
that that's of course correct it may be
i just don't know that's a political
question and it's not a question for me
to answer
you know and the question that i'm
answering is is this a good investment
and the conclusion that i come to is no
um and that's all i have to say about
this um and so now you can ask me
like are there other experiments in the
foundations of physics there would be
good investments
uh and uh in these cases you know there
are some cases where i would say
um yes most likely you know i can't be
sure
but at least um the um
expected return on investment is not as
terribly bad as it is
uh for this for this bigger collider and
uh if you look at the societal context
it's an incredibly difficult question to
answer where i just can't make any
you know sweeping statements especially
now
with the economic situation looking so
difficult i just think it's
irresponsible you know
to say well please give us 40 billion
dollar to build this larger thing and
uh we can't tell you really what's going
to come out of it but you will make a
lot of
particle physicists happy i'm i'm sorry
like you know do you really to expect me
to sign this
well i guess the question is you know a
lot of things in physics that have led
to great breakthroughs
um and i've written about this are
serendipitous and you know the hardest
thing in life is planning on serendipity
to
to save you uh from an experiment but i
guess that you know the counter argument
would be
well there are aspects of of building an
apparatus that just scale with energy or
energy to some power
and uh yes there's if you if you really
if you know there's a no-go theorem so
to speak of you know that there's a
forbidden
you know uh region of energy space a
parameter space of cross-section etc
um then yes then i would say you know
looking for something that's forbidden
and is demonstrably so that is a waste
of time and we're not good stewards of
taxpayer money
i i guess you know there is the other
there is the other and here's this is uh
image from uh your website just when you
talk about the cern
um you know marketing video as you call
it uh and there is a strong sociology
because i think you know in eric
weinstein's words
you know that that we're sort of really
fighting over these crumbs of the last
great revolution
and i wonder you know when you when you
think about it i don't know if you've
ever heard of this
book or theory it's called the fourth
turning
you ever heard of this it's this guy
neil howe and another guy i think
strauss
they write about these these paradigm
shifts in society
where you go basically centered around
wars or famines
or revolutions that lead to different um
different periods of social upheaval and
then recovery
and i wonder you know he characterizes a
period of war
you know as obviously maximal upheaval
but offering
in the recovery phase like the baby
boomer phase uh so to speak
you know a chance for great wealth and
prosperity and i wonder
do you see any parallels with physics
and that you know we
we've had we had a tremendous number of
breakthroughs in the 20th century um
and uh and maybe uh by some estimates
you know we're still
we're still making tremendous progress
and even in the uh foundations of
physics
some you know one of my readers sent me
a list of like eight different
huge breakthroughs in his opinion
ranging from things like jim peeble's
work on perturbation theory in the
cosmos to
quantum teleportation these are big
breakthroughs in
in foundational fundamental aspects of
physics but nevertheless
do you think we might just be in a lull
between these different seasons of
of the society of physics the culture of
physics where we're on the precipice of
a great breakthrough
well so i don't know this um
societal um theory that you just talked
about but it sounds very similar to
uh kuhn's model of scientific revolution
right so you have these upheavals
and then you have some period of normal
signs where everything flourishes and so
on
so if you're asking like do we need do
we need the next revolution
uh the answer is basically yes um and
so you're noting that um
there are still things happening in the
foundations of physics is not that
people are just sitting around
twittering their thumbs
that's certainly correct you know just
because you do normal science doesn't
mean you're doing you do know science
um but the thing is that
we have these big problems in the
foundations of physics
that have remained unsolved for more
than 80 years
um basically if you think of something
like dark matter or what's the
quantization of gravity
um what's with the interpretation of
quantum mechanics right
so these are not new questions and there
has been zero progress
on that like nothing but that doesn't
mean that
uh uh there are no other things that
people have done
as you point out uh certainly there have
been um
other things so um
yeah i'm not sure if this if this
answers uh your question
so um yeah i i think it does i mean the
main thing is that
um you know there is a cycle where you
have
the public who has a vested interests
and fiduciary
responsible people taking care of their
their money their stewardship of their
of their finances they also have an
interest in the results of the science
as much as you know we scientists are
not great at exposing you know what
really fascinating work we're working on
um and then there's this you know kind
of hype
you know mini cycle where you know you
have your university press office
and you've got your you know your local
newspapers etc that want to build up the
research that's going on
and i just wonder you know in an era
since we're experiencing now this great
you know potentially this great
recession or whatever
might even be worse in this era of
declining
you know budget dollars where do you
think people should spend their time
in other words it's not for lack of
brain power i can point to 20 people
working on dark matter and dark energy
um what do you think it will really be
that that
leads to you know the most bang for the
buck or return on investment
given that we live in a constrained
resource environment in other words why
shouldn't we spend money on covid
research and
and crispr and you know and devote that
to dark matter
you know discovering aspects of dark
matter yes that's exactly the right
question to ask um so maybe let me
briefly return to something you uh said
earlier you were
talking about the uh serendipity
um that um led to
many breakthroughs uh this is this is
another one of
uh the nonsense nonsense arguments on my
list
uh because um you can make this argument
about any experiment
right any experiment that tests
something that has previously been
untested
you can say well you know we could just
be lucky and find something
so what you should do in this situation
you should choose that
investment that is most likely to give
you um the biggest bang
for um the least amount of bucks
basically
and uh collide this bigger collider just
fast very very badly because it's
a lot of bug and very very unlikely to
do any bang
and so what you're what you're saying is
exactly the right question to ask like
where are you most likely
uh to make some breakthrough now you say
something about you know covet
research and so on um again if if you
want me to
make any statements about societal
relevance i think i'm really not
qualified to do that
that's a very involved question i would
just vaguely say
that whenever you are thinking about
science investment you have to think
um in very very different time scales
you know there is research that is going
to be
important right now like this covet
stuff
and there's research that's going to be
important in the next 10
20 years like say anything about um
genetic therapies what have you uh and
then there's research that's going to be
important
in two three hundred years or something
and that's where you can put high energy
particle physics or foundations of
quantum mechanics and that kind of stuff
and so to have some kind of balanced
budget
you should you should cover all of that
um
in in a certain division so that that's
the that's the uh difficult part you
work out
in early ill i leave that uh to an uh
economist
so so that's for what the overall
societal
um problem is concerned and i'll i'll
leave it at that
so now if if you look at the foundation
of physics specifically i feel much more
qualified
to say something um because what i've
basically presented in my book is an
answer to exactly this
question like um what are the areas that
you should be focusing on where you are
most likely to make progress
and the way that i um
present this argument is by looking at
the history of physics
like you can you can ask if you look at
the history
where has progress come from and so yes
there has been experimental progress of
course
so there were these discoveries uh of uh
liberty this is a terrible word
but uh um so the problem with those is
um that um new experiments are getting
uh more and more expensive and it takes
a longer time
to build them uh so just um you know
poking in the dark by building
experiments that's not an option anymore
we're way past uh the stage and this
puts a heavy burden on
theorists because um they have to um
you know come up with arguments for
what's the next experiment that we
should be doing
um and so that's why theorists have to
be really really careful
with um what um argumentation they uh
rely on
and now um this brings us to the other
type of breakthroughs uh that we have
seen
uh in the foundations of physics which
were those that were led by theoretical
predictions
and now it's very interesting if you
look at the cases where this has
actually happened
it was always by solving an
inconsistency
in the existing theories and by this i
mean just a mathematical disagreement
if you think about um for example
einstein's um
uh you know special relativity and also
general relativity
um the the former was an inconsistency
between the galilean and variants
and maxwell's equations it's just the
wrong invariants
um and then once you have special
relativity you notice well that's
actually incompatible with newtonian
gravity
so you have created another
inconsistency that requires a solution
that brings you to general relativity
and then once you have special
relativity
you also notice that this didn't fit
together with the original formulation
of quantum mechanics
and resolving this and consistency
that's what dirac did
and so yes dirac was talking a lot about
the beauty of his solution
but he also had a really really good
problem to solve in the first place
and so this is i think the reason why
these
mathematical uh breakthroughs uh worked
because they had these inconsistencies
and they're they're other examples for
example the hicks um the hicks solves an
actual inconsistency
now if you look at all the failed
predictions in the past 40 years
these were not um
theoretical predictions that were based
on solving an inconsistency
they were based on wanting to make the
theory more beautiful
and so the answer that i come to
towards the end of the book is focus on
solving
real inconsistencies if you want to make
theoretical progress
that's what you should be doing and so
this returns us to this issue with
the question should we build a larger
collider um
in this energy range that the next
larger collider
could be testing there are no
inconsistencies that require solution
and that's that's a situation which is
entirely different
to the situation for the large hadron
collider where you knew you had you have
these unitary problems that required a
solution that that was an actual
inconsistency
so we knew that something had to happen
not necessarily the hicks but there had
to be some solution to that
so um we knew that we would see
something new
and yeah well the hicks it was but for
the next bigger collider there just
isn't anything
remotely like that the next
inconsistency in the standard model is
somewhere where
um um the issue with the neutrino masses
becomes relevant and that's not until
i forget 10 to the 13 gb or something
like that
so it's way way off you're not going to
get there um
so you should be um focusing then on
more promising inconsistencies you some
something that's uh
close around the corner dark matter is
like the obvious
candidate to name right because in in
that case
okay so this is not a theoretical
internal inconsistency but
it's an inconsistency between the
theories and um observations and
in this case at least we do have
observations so we have we have
something to build on
and then um there are other
inconsistencies like
the missing quantization of um gravity
is an actual inconsistency
it doesn't fit together with the
standard model um that's the measurement
problem in quantum mechanics
and there are some there are other
mathematical problems
in quantum field theory um themselves
and now the problem is this returns me
to what i said in the very beginning
solving these problems is really really
really hard
and so people are not going to do it on
on a short term grant
if they have to produce results quickly
what they will be doing instead is that
they will do the easier stuff
and that's producing these piecemeal
little tiny incremental
things that you can publish and you can
put on your cv and then you will get a
job
so speaking of that we we both have to
get back to our
respective jobs uh i had about 20 more
questions to ask you maybe we'll do a
part two
over the summer because i do want to
talk about big astronomy projects which
also suffer from potentially their own
success you know being victims of their
own success
in in the past and you know and and just
making it so
expensive to build you know this project
cmb stage four
experiment uh the experiment i'm
involved with called the simon's
observatory is a 100 million dollar
class project
cmb stage four could be more and and as
usual
we only quote that's all peanuts
well but remember when you quote an
experiment it's always uh
it's only just the capital cost not the
operating expenses so
you should double all the costs you see
from whenever you see an experimentalist
give you a number always double it
but the last question i do want to ask
you in the last couple of minutes
you've had a remarkable career you've
done many different things
and have acted as a role model for
physicists
in all different disciplines and young
people in particular
i wonder based on the name of our
podcast which is the into the impossible
podcast that derives from arthur c
clarke's law that the only way to find
out what is what is possible is to
venture a bit
beyond into the impossible i always like
to ask my guest what
fact of life or what aspect of your life
um made no sense or seemed impossible
when you were in your 20s
perhaps and now makes perfect sense
because you ventured into the impossible
so to speak
so advice to your former self uh
oh my god um let me maybe uh
say one thing though you speak of my
great career
let me point out that i don't have a
permanent position i sit on short-term
money
um so i i'm working on some project uh
and the funding on that will run out
uh in three years and then god knows
what
so much about my great so buy more books
buy every single copy i've got all three
different versions
yeah um i mean so
what what didn't make sense to me in the
so
i've always had a very strong interest
in philosophy that i always as a
physicist felt
was somewhat of a waste of time because
you know scientists tend to be very
dismissive
you know of your philosophical interests
and now i'm glad i paid some attention
to it because
it turned out to be much more important
uh to my research than
i had ever anticipated that's
fascinating thank you sabine
so where can people find you online and
uh and when can they expect your next
book after this one
um so how do you find me online you know
my my name is
not very common you google my name and
i'm you know i'm like the first 100 hits
and and i'm on youtube and i'm on
blogger and i'm on facebook and i'm on
twitter i'm everywhere
yeah so we'll give you we'll give folks
links what are you working on
it's not difficult um
and then what are you working on in
terms of a future book i heard rumors
that you might be working
oh yeah um yeah i'm supposed to be
writing a book
um but you know covet got in the way
so uh it's it's not moving a lot uh but
yeah so
um i have a deadline next year next
summer
and it will be about physics again okay
it's not so hard
to guess and it's about all those deep
philosophical questions that your
physics professor told you not to ask
wonderful i can't wait to read it i'm
sure it'll be another bestseller like
lost in math which comes out
now by the time you're listening to this
video or an audio it'll be out
in bookstores in america and i just want
to thank you sabine for
sharing your time your ideas and again
as an inspiration to
many young people because of your uh the
rare quality
one of the rarest qualities of all is
your courage and i do look up to that
and i thank you for sharing your ideas
and most importantly sharing that
vanishing quantity called time so now
i'll
release you back into the woods and
enjoy the rest of your evening there in
germany
thank you for the lovely conversation
bye savina